[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend zum dritten mal in einem
monat und gleich fünf tage am stück die
lokführergewerkschaft gdl zeigt härte ob
sie dabei über zieht sondern auch vor
gericht geklärt werden die bahn hatte
einen eilantrag von frankfurter
arbeitsgericht gestellt nach ansicht der
bahn manager ist der streik rechtlich
unzulässig weil es der gewerkschaft
nicht nur um konkrete arbeitsbedingungen
und den tarifvertrag gehe sondern auch
um darüber hinausgehende rechtliche und
politische themen dafür sind streiks
nicht vorgesehen also statt man sich
heute wieder im gerichtssaal gegenüber
das gab's schon mal 2014 gleiche
konstellation damals gelang es der bahn
nicht den streik per gerichtsbeschluss
zu stoppen und auch dieses mal war der
versuch erfolglos zumindest in erster
instanz das urteil kam vor einer
dreiviertelstunde die bahn hat
allerdings berufung angekündigt aber
erstmal wird weiter gestreikt ans
irgendwie berichtet
leere bahnsteige
ausgefallene verbindungen auch bei der
s-bahn wie hier in berlin drangvolle
enge dagegen wenn doch ein zug fuhr zum
dritten mal in vier wochen bestreikt die
gdl die deutsche bahn und das obwohl der
staatskonzern kurz vor streikbeginn noch
ein verbessertes angebot vorgelegt hatte
am morgen die reaktion des
gewerkschaftsvorsitzenden der streik
geht weiter
wenn man auf die materiellen dinge
schaut dann sieht man dass in 2021 weder
eine gehaltserhöhung noch eine prämie
kommt ich rede von dem schriftlichen
angebot von gestern abend zweitens die
betriebsrente wird gekürzt und das ist
schon allein diese beiden elemente sind
nicht geeignet um zu verhandeln darüber
hinaus liegen bahn und gdl aber nicht
mehr weit auseinander
3,2 prozent gehaltserhöhung fordert die
gewerkschaft bei 28 monaten laufzeit und
600 euro ohne prämie 3,2 prozent will
die bahn auch bezahlen bietet jetzt 36
statt vorher 40 monaten laufzeit und ist
seit gestern auch zu einer corona prämie
von bis zu 600 euro bereit es gibt mit
diesem schritt nun wirklich überhaupt
keinen grund mehr nun nicht an den
verhandlungstisch zu kommen und deswegen
fordere ich die gdl-spitze auf die
blockadehaltung endlich aufzugeben offen
ließ der bahn vorstand allerdings ob die
gehälter in einem ersten schritt im
nächsten oder noch in diesem jahr
angehoben werden ebenso wie die
fortführung der bisherigen
betriebsrenten auf beides besteht die
gdl es geht der lokführergewerkschaft
aber auch darum sich gegenüber der weit
größeren eisenbahn und
verkehrsgewerkschaft evg zu profilieren
als bessere arbeitnehmervertretung zu
punkten denn bei der bahn gilt seit
januar das tarif einheits gesetz wonach
nur tarifverträge der gewerkschaft mit
mehr mitgliedern im jeweiligen betriebs
teil zur anwendung kommen das könnte die
harte haltung der gdl befördert haben so
experten mehrheits gewerkschaft wird man
aber nicht indem man brav ist in dem man
zuhört sondern neben dem man selbst
initiative beweis indem man
aufmerksamkeit erzeugt konflikte eingeht
und in diesem sinne dann deutlich macht
dass man eigentlich die bessere die
echte hre die authentische gewerkschaft
ist die nämlich mehr raus holt für die
beschäftigten und damit auch die
existenzberechtigung hat als größere
gewerkschaft in die nächste runde zu
gehen so kämpft die
lokführergewerkschaft um ihre bedeutung
im bahn konzern will erklärtermaßen
wachsen und ihren einflussbereich
erweitern war sie bisher nur für das
fahrende bahn personal zuständig für
alle anderen berufe die evg sowie die
gdl diesmal und künftig auch
fahrdienstleiter bahnhofs und
werkstattpersonal rangieren und
gleisbauer vertreten eine kampfansage an
die konkurrenz gewerkschaft
gdl versucht jetzt ihre zukunft zu
sichern indem sie sich aus ihrem
eigentlichen organisationsbereich
nämlich den lokführern herausbewegt in
dem bereich der fahrdienstleiter der
aufsichten der stellwerke der werker um
damit überleben zu können währenddessen
müssen pendler und reisende sich darauf
einstellen dass der arbeitskampf noch
bis zum frühen dienstagmorgen der
nächsten woche andauern wird die bahn
ging heute mit einem eilantrag dagegen
vor unterlag aber der streik geht weiter
dass afghanistan debakel hat den
europäern einmal mehr vor augen geführt
was sie nicht sind eine militärische
großmacht ohne die amerikaner konnten
sie nichts ausrichten noch nicht mal
einen flughafen sichern würden sich alle
europäischen armeen zusammenschließen
wäre das natürlich schon eine erhebliche
kraft aber wie sollte das gehen es gibt
keine gemeinsame europäische
außenpolitik und damit auch keine
gemeinsame verteidigungspolitik
könnte man aber nicht wenigstens eine
gemeinsame eingreiftruppe haben zum
beispiel für solche fälle wie jetzt die
evakuierungsaktion in kabul darum ging
es heute auch beim treffen der eu
verteidigungsminister in slowenien die
idee einer solchen euro truppe ist uralt
die konzepte liegen schon ewig in
schubladen das hauptargument dagegen war
bisher immer das ist ja schon die nato
gibt doch die zeiten haben sich geändert
anne gellinek berichtet
es sind diese bilder die den
europäischen verteidigungsminister im
fernen slowenien richtig wehtun die
taliban in amerikanischer beute uniform
kontrollieren jeden menschen jedes
fahrzeug das sich dem flughafen von
kabul mehr siegesbewusst zielen sie auf
kameras die botschaft wir haben das
sagen der westen verloren europa fühlt
sich doppelt geschlagen vertrieben von
den taliban und militärisch machtlos
ohne die usa
wir haben in afghanistan gesehen dass
wir mit blick auf unsere eigenen
fähigkeiten nicht so weit sind wie wir
uns das selbst vorgestellt haben wir
waren von den amerikanern abhängig und
es wird heute darum gehen die richtigen
schlüsse zu ziehen beim treffen der eu
verteidigungsminister wird die neue alte
idee einer schnellen eu eingreiftruppe
diskutiert mindestens 5000 männer und
frauen aus nationalen armeen die
gemeinsam trainieren und schnell
eingesetzt werden könnten theoretisch
wenn alle mitmachten ich halte nichts
davon jetzt einfach aus der hüfte heraus
schlussfolgerung zu ziehen ich glaube
dass es wichtig ist dass wir über eine
europäische sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik
diskutieren dass wir kräfte bündeln und
in diese richtung müssen wir jetzt der
tiefen und zwar schnell zumal es
gemeinsame kampftruppen längst gibt
schon 2007 wurden sogenannte europäische
battlegroups ins leben gerufen
eingesetzt wurden sie jedoch nie die
entscheidungsprozesse zu langwierig
außerdem stritten die europäer jedes mal
über sinn und unsinn einer möglichen
mission der lettische
verteidigungsminister kritisiert deshalb
manchen europäern fehle schlicht der
wille militär auch einzusetzen
länder wie deutschland zum beispiel
müssen ihre bürger überzeugen dass sich
die welt verändert hat allein mit guten
worten kann man leute wie die taliban
nicht überzeugen wenn wir mehr tun
sollen dann müssen wir dann können wir
das dann braucht es aber dazu auf den
politischen willen und ich glaube am
verteidigungsministerium und dieser
regierung verteidigt das nicht ein
bisschen wahlkampf auch in slowenien die
verteidigungsministerin lässt offen was
sie von einer eingreiftruppe hält und
versucht zu vermitteln eine koalition
der willigen solle vorangehen und
gemeinsam üben eine arbeitsgruppe
feststellen woran ist den europäern
fehlt dass die eu in naher zukunft eine
militär operation wie die sicherung des
flughafens von kabul durchführen kann
daran glauben wohl auch die optimisten
unter den eu ministern nicht
zahnklinik also nahe zukunft nicht das
haben wir gehört aber wie ist deine
einschätzung kommt da jetzt
grundsätzlich was in gang mit dieser
eingreiftruppe
also ich glaube man kann schon sagen
dass die diskussion über eine größere
militärische eigenständigkeit der
europäischen union schon an fahrt
aufgenommen hat und es gibt auch mehr eu
länder die sich jetzt zumindest
theoretisch eine solche eingreiftruppe
vorstellen können man schätzt ungefähr
die hälfte der eu mitgliedstaaten
könnten sich dazu irgendwie bekennen
aber die probleme bei dieser kampftruppe
sind auch noch die gleichen es gibt die
befürworter darunter ford zuvorderst
frankreich als nato skeptiker immer
bereit die militärische eigenständigkeit
der eu zu fördern und es gibt die
kritiker das sind die osteuropäer
glühende nato anhänger die fürchten dass
eine solche eu eingreiftruppe eine
konkurrenzveranstaltung zur nato werden
könnte und diese eben schwächen zweites
problem ist dass es keine gemeinsame
sicherheitspolitik der europäischen
union gibt dass also die einzelnen
mitgliedstaaten die gefährdung ihrer
sicherheit höchst unterschiedlich
definieren die mittelmeeranrainer würden
wohl eher die gefahr aus afrika sehen
während die beiden heute ganz klar
gesagt haben ihm sei afghanistan
ziemlich egal ihnen ging es um die
grenze zu bildungs und dritter punkt der
die sache schwierig macht ist die
entscheidungsfindung man braucht immer
noch einstimmigkeit für einen solchen
einsatz also gemeinsam militärischen
druck nicht stattdessen muss man mit den
taliban reden
gibt es da auf europäischer ebene
konzepte für diese gespräche
die eu-außenminister die sich heute
abend hier in cannes in slowenien auch
noch treffen sitzen noch beim abendessen
und versuchen eine gemeinsame haltung
der eu zu definieren wie man mit den
taliban umgehen könnte ganz klar ist
dass man technische gespräche mit den
neuen machthabern in kabul führen muss
da sind sich alle einig eben um dafür zu
sorgen dass ortskräfte und
schützenswerte personen das land noch
verlassen können eine politische
anerkennung einer möglichen neuen
taliban-regierung die will man erst mal
nicht zu sagen sondern die ist ein ganz
klare bedingungen geknüpft eben an die
einhaltung von menschen- und
frauenrechte auch daran dass das
afghanistan keine neue zuflucht für
terrorgruppen ist und dass eben die
grenzen offen bleiben in dieser frage
hofft die eu dass die taliban einsehen
dass die entwicklungshilfe die die eu im
moment gestoppt hat brauchen sollte
brauchen könnten für den wiederaufbau
des landes sie hofft darauf dass die
taliban so zu sagen diesen hebel der eu
anerkennen und möglicherweise diese
bedingungen erfüllen aber sicher ist man
nicht jetzt liegt erstmal der fokus
darauf ortskräfte rauszuholen und die
grenzen offenzuhalten dankeschön eine
gellinek ja mal sehen wie sehr die
taliban geld und anerkennung der
europäer brauchen werden sie teilten
heute erstmal mit china ihr wichtigster
partner sein china sei bereit in
afghanistan zu investieren für die
chinesin ist afghanistan in der tat ein
wichtiger teil ihres globalen
seidenstraßen projekts mit
menschenrechtsfragen hält man sich in
peking bekanntlich eh nicht auf und das
passt also aber auch in der
vergangenheit mangelte es den taliban
offenkundig nicht an geldquellen für
waffenkäufe bestechung und was man sonst
noch so braucht und wieder die macht zu
übernehmen um eine ganze volkswirtschaft
am laufen zu halten dürfte das
allerdings nicht genügen über die
finanzen der taliban berichtet kamera
mafia
die taliban die neuen herrscher
afghanistans eines der ärmsten länder
der welt dennoch ihre kriegskasse kann
sich sehen lassen über eine milliarde
dollar schwer das sagt hans jakob
schindler er war beim un-sicherheitsrat
zuständig für die überwachung der
finanzströme der taliban
also über letzten 20 jahre haben die
taliban nie finanz probleme gehabt sie
hatten drei einnahme töpfe das erste war
der anbau und der internationale
vertrieb von drogen in afghanistan der
zweite top war die ausbeutung der
afghanischen wirtschaft auch durch
steuern und das dritte waren spenden von
ausländischen sympathisanten direkt
anbieten
der drogenhandel die wichtigste
geldquelle der islamisten in afghanistan
werden laut vereinten nationen 85
prozent des weltweiten opium aufkommens
angebaut besonders in diesen gebieten
sie haben in den letzten 20 jahren vom
aussaat über die ernte bis zu den
laboren und den internationalen handel
die gesamte den gesamten kreislauf des
drogenhandels in afghanistan
kontrolliert und damit mehrere hundert
millionen us dollar im jahr verdient am
höchsten punkt letzten jahr waren es
nach un schätzungen ungefähr 400
millionen us dollar
eine ähnlich hohe summe bringen den
gotteskriegern erpressungs gelder und
steuern auf vermögen wegstrecken oder
exporten und sie haben zugriff auf
rohstoffe am hindukusch afghanistan
liegt auf einem schatz
bodenschätze für die sich viele länder
interessieren gold edelsteine kupfer
lithium
es lägen rohstoffe mit einem ungefähren
wert von über einer billion unter der
erde afghanistans diese ressourcen sind
natürlich für viele länder von großem
interesse allen voran china
auch die taliban setzen künftig vor
allem auf gelder aus china wie ihr
sprecher zuletzt sagte
wir haben sehr gute beziehungen zu china
es ist unser wichtigster partner und
eine außergewöhnliche chance denn china
ist bereit zu investieren und unser land
neu aufzubauen
mit zuwendungen aus den golfstaaten
haben die taliban insgesamt über eine
milliarde dollar auf dem konto genug für
eine islamistengruppe zu wenig um einen
staat zu unterhalten sie brauchen den
zugriff auf das geld afghanistans und
die internationalen hilfsgelder über
vier milliarden dollar pro jahr
westliche hilfsgelder noch ein fast 70
prozent des staatshaushaltes
afghanistans aus die taliban sind auf
diese gelder angewiesen um regieren zu
können der westen kann diese hilfsgelder
wenn er sie klug einsetzt an bedingungen
knüpfen um die taliban zu beeinflussen
hinsichtlich der menschen und der
frauenrechte
ob die taliban auf diesen deal eingehen
es bleibt eines der großen unbekannten
afghanistans
und jetzt gibt es erstmal andere
meldungen zunächst unter zunächst zur
krone situation die infektionszahlen
steigen weiter an das robert koch
institut meldet 13
1715 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 1089 mehr als vor einer woche
die sieben tage incident steigt auf
76,9
374 corona infizierte kamen innerhalb
eines tages neu ins krankenhaus die
sieben tage incidents hier 1,74 diese
sogenannten hospitalisierung zahlen
zeigen allerdings nur einen trend weil
die meldungen zum teil verzögert sind
die ausläufer von hurrikan ida haben im
nordosten der usa für extreme unwetter
gesorgt für new york city und new jersey
musste nach tagelangem dauerregen der
notstand ausgerufen werden mindestens 14
menschen kamen ums leben es sind die
stärksten regenfälle dort seit beginn
der wetteraufzeichnungen auch u bahn
stationen wurden von den wassermassen
überflutet große teile des öffentlichen
verkehrs kamen zum erliegen
polen hat in der grenzregion zu belarus
den ausnahmezustand verhängt auf antrag
der regierung unterzeichnete präsident
du da einen entsprechenden erlass in
einem drei kilometer breiten streifen
entlang der grenze geht nun unter
anderem ein versammlungsverbot die
polnische regierung beschuldigt den
belarussischen machthaber lukaschenko in
organisierter form flüchtlinge aus
krisenregionen an die eu außengrenze zu
bringen
in frankfurt am main hat der bau einer
jüdischen akademie begonnen heute war
feierliche erster spatenstich dazu kamen
unter anderem der präsident des
zentralrates der juden in deutschland
josef schuster und hessens
ministerpräsident volker bouffier in der
akademie soll es in seminaren und
vorträgen um jüdische perspektiven zu
politik philosophie und kultur gehen
2024 soll die akademie ihren betrieb
aufnehmen
gut drei wochen vor der bundestagswahl
hat die bundeszentrale für politische
bildung wieder den wahlomat
freigeschaltet mit dem online angebot
kann die eigene haltung anhand von 38
thesen mit der position der einzelnen
parteien verglichen werden neu ist
diesmal unter anderem dass positionen
aller parteien direkt miteinander
verglichen werden können
bleiben noch beim wahlkampf früher
sprach man ja davon dass in den letzten
wahlkampfwochen jeden tag eine neue sau
durchs dorf getrieben werde dieses
sprach bild ist im zeitalter
industrieller landwirtschaft zwar etwas
aus der zeit gefallen im kern aber immer
noch richtig heute hat es die grünen
erwischt der grüne finanzminister von
baden württemberg hat ein digitales
hinweis portal gestartet mit dem
steuerbetrug angezeigt werden kann das
konnte man bei finanzbehörden bisher
zwar auch schon schriftlich oder per
telefon das neue internet tool macht
anonyme anzeigen aber besonders leicht
ein gefundenes fressen für die
politische konkurrenz die über blockwart
mentalität und stasi methoden schöpft
eva schiller eigentlich sollte das
hinweisgebersystem ein digitales
vorzeigeprojekt von baden württembergs
grünem finanzminister seien seit mai im
amt aufgefallen durch hartnäckige fragen
im wirecard untersuchungsausschuss gibt
bei es gerne den jäger auf steuersünder
seit montag können bürger ganz
unkompliziert online ihren verdacht auf
steuerbetrug bekunden und das ist neu
anonym mit dem finanzamt kommunizieren
es geht hier nicht um solche fälle wurde
eine nachbarin anderen nachbarn
anschwärzen weil er die putzfrau
möglicherweise nicht angemeldet hat
dafür haben wir gar nicht die
kapazitäten das alles im detail super
folgen es geht um relevante und
substanzielle fälle von steuerbetrug das
ministerium hatte noch überlegt ob das
portal überhaupt eine pressemeldung wert
ist man hatte nicht gerechnet mit der
skandalisierung spirale im zähen phrasen
wahlkampf die bild -zeitung beginnt mit
dem begriff steuer stasi die csu
beschuldigt die grünen misstrauen unter
nachbarn zu sehen auch die fdp spricht
von denunziantentum wenn man damit
rechnen muss dass der nachbar möglich
falsche schlüsse zieht ein unberechtigt
anzeigt dann wird man vorsichtiger dann
wird man misstrauisch dann ist man nicht
mehr so frei in seinem alltagsverhalten
und das ist für unsere gesellschaft
schlecht in einem tv-interview springt
die grüne kanzlerkandidatin baerbock
baden württembergs finanzminister zur
seite wir müssen orte schaffen wo auch
gemeldet werden kann wenn man weiß dass
es zu heftigen steuerbetrug kommt und
das wird jetzt in baden württemberg
gemacht und eigentlich wäre das auch
aufgabe eines bundesfinanzministers
gewesen der bundesfinanzminister spd
spitzenkandidat scholz der sich nächste
woche diesem tv format stellt wendet
sich sofort gegen behr box pläne
ich bin überzeugt dass wir
erstklassige finanzämter in deutschland
haben die ihre arbeit leisten und da
brauchen wir keine neuen techniken steht
dazu führen dass der eine über den
anderen reden und armin laschet der
schweiz zu unserer frage was die cdu vom
steuerbetrugs portal hält was womöglich
daran liegt dass nordrhein westfalens
finanzverwaltung bereits mit anonymen
online hinweisen arbeitet das
eigentliche problem sei doch finden
steuerberater dass die finanzbehörden
unterbesetzt sind uns ist einfach
bekannt dass die finanzverwaltung die
daten die sie jetzt schon bekommt über
kontrollmitteilungen nicht nachkommt
diese daten auszuwerten und deshalb
halte ich es für sehr fraglich ob die
finanzverwaltung mit noch zusätzlichen
meldungen überhaupt überhaupt fertig
wird und dies bewältigen kann verfolgt
würden nur die großen fische entgegnet
finanzminister weyers 50 milliarden euro
gehen deutschland jährlich durch
steuerbetrug verloren für ihn grund
genug an seiner hinweis plattform
festzuhalten
eins macht weiter zunächst mit einem
digital thema was kompliziert klingt
aber wirklich viele menschen betrifft
der europäische gerichtshof hat sich in
mehreren urteilen zu internetangeboten
mit sogenannten null tarif optionen
befasst anders waren
rechtsstreitigkeiten in deutschland
frank wittmann ich hoffe da ist er worum
geht es da genau ja die höchsten
europäischen richter haben
zusatzangebote der telekom und vodafone
untersagt weil diese angebote gegen die
gleichbehandlung von daten verstoßen
haben konkret ging es um dienste bei
denen man zum beispiel filme auf sein
smartphone oder tablet streamen konnte
ohne dass dafür das monatliche
datenvolumen belastet wurde später
schränkten die unternehmen ihre angebote
aber ein die videos konnte man
beispielsweise nur noch in schlechterer
qualität schauen eine von mehreren
benachteiligungen gegenüber anderen
angeboten grundsätzlich monierten die
richter dass diese null tarif option ein
hohes gut missachten nämlich die
netzneutralität sie besagte internet
anbieter sind verpflichtet unabhängig
von tarifen alle daten gleich zu
behandeln keine zweiklassengesellschaft
im netz bei der beispielsweise daten
gegen zusätzliche gebühren schneller
oder in besserer qualität gesendet
werden würden als andere stattdessen der
grundsatz alle daten gleich schnell das
ist fair neutral netz neutral wer ist
das ganze im übrigen nicht nur für die
nutzer also für die verbraucher die
netzneutralität sichert auch den
wettbewerb den könnten sich unternehmen
die vorfahrt auf der datenautobahn
erkaufen da sind sich die experten
ziemlich sicher würde das kleinere
unternehmen oder start ups in hohem maß
benachteiligen frank bethmann vielen
dank und eine weitere entscheidung des
europäischen gerichtshofs betrifft das
deutsche energierecht und die rolle der
regulierungsbehörden dennoch soll der
bundesnetzagentur die unter anderem für
die regulierung der strom und gasnetze
zuständig ist mehr unabhängigkeit
eingeholt werden die eu kommission war
vor gericht gegen deutschland
vorgegangen sie ist der auffassung dass
die agentur ohne politische vorgaben
handeln sollte
knapp zwei jahre nach dem spektakulären
diebstahl aus dem grünen gewölbe in
dresden ist anklage gegen sechs
tatverdächtige erhoben worden den
männern wird unter anderem schwere
schwerer bandendiebstahl und
brandstiftung vorgeworfen im november
2009 10 sollen die mutmaßlichen diebe in
das grüne gewölbe eingebrochen sein und
schmuckstücke und juwelen im wert von
mindestens 113 millionen euro gestohlen
haben
die legendäre popgruppe aber hat fast 40
jahre nach der trennung der band ein
neues album angekündigt das studio album
der vier wird den titel tragen wie die
band heute bekannt gab zwei neue lieder
waren auch gleich zu hören
si
sie hätten im frühjahr
1982 eine auszeit genommen und jetzt den
entschluss gefasst diese auszeit zu
beenden aber
[Musik]
jeder kennt ihn sehr thaqi aus dem film
alexis sorbas das kampflied wurde fast
so etwas wie die britische nationalhymne
und dann weltweiter exportschlager für
feste aller art der komponist war über
diesen erfolg übrigens eher genervt denn
mikis theodorakis hatte so viel andere
musik geschaffen bis hin zu opern und
oratorien
doch die vielen werke standen immer ein
bisschen im schatten des berühmten
tanzes des großen krieg
das war er selbst auch ein großer
grieche musiker freiheitskämpfer
nationalheld
nun ist mikis theodorakis im alter von
96 jahren gestorben
ein nachruf von andreas postel
nur diese zwei töne braucht - wie in die
griechen liebevoll nennen umwelt ruhm zu
erlangen seine komposition zu diesem
merkwürdig improvisierten sehr tag ideen
anthony quinn als alexis sorbas tanzt
wie ein stein hin diese melodie am bein
hat er einmal gesagt der natürlich nie
auf diese zwei töne reduziert werden
wollte sein leben selbst war eine
sinfonie
geboren am 29 juli 1925 auf der insel
kosmetischen mehr fällt er früh durch
seine außergewöhnliche musikalische
begabung auf leben und werk gehören bei
theodorakis eng zusammen seine biografie
geprägt vom widerstand gegen die
faschistischen besatzungstruppen im
zweiten weltkrieg dem anschließenden
bürgerkrieg und der griechischen
militärdiktatur
das komponieren war für mich ein ausweg
so wie ein gestrandeter im glauben an
seine rettung eine flaschenpost ins meer
wirft sagte einmal über sich
mehrmals in gefangenschaft wurde
theodorakis schwer gefoltert seine musik
während der militärdiktatur verboten
nur dank internationaler fürsprache kann
er 1970 ins exil nach paris gehen
sein freund und verleger peter hanser
strecker erinnert sich
bekannt und sehr beliebt und in der
schwierigen zeit als er auch verhaftet
war und seine musik sogar verboten war
griechenland haben sich große
komponisten und am bernstein und
schostakowitsch für seine freilassung
eingesetzt und das bezeichnet ihn
wirklich dass er weltweit eine ganz
große stimme und eine großes ansehen
hatte
seine lieder werden auf der straße genau
sowieso in dem konzertsaal dabei
dirigiert er wie ein adler heißt es über
seine imposante erscheinung diadora es
vor als bekennender linker auch in der
ddr populär mehrere seiner werke werden
im osten deutschlands uraufgeführt so
auch canto general nachdichtungen von
pablo neruda mit zunehmendem alter
weicht die linke ideologie es gebe nur
den kampf um freiheit und demokratie
nichts weiter
jetzt am ende meines lebens kann ich
sagen dass ich genau das gemacht habe
was ich machen wollte ich fühle mich
nicht rechtfertigen und sagen ich ging
so weit wie die umstände es mir
erlaubten nein ich ging so weit ich eben
konnte weiter konnte ich nicht
in seiner heimat heißt es mit es habe
die griechische seele in die sprache der
musik übersetzen können so dass die welt
sie versteht mit einer dreitägigen
staatstrauer nimmt das land nun abschied
von der stimme griechenlands
[Musik]
das war es von uns bevor wir gleich den
stab an die kollegen vom sport
weiterreichen noch der hinweis auf
maybrit illner bei ihr diskutieren heute
unter anderem fdp chef christian lindner
und die spd vorsitzende saskia esken
über wirtschafts und sozialpolitik und
um 0.40 meldet sich dann christopher
wehrmann mit unserem heute-journal
update
[Musik]
genannt das ist wirklich ein sehr groß
ist ein sehr mächtiges hoch dass sich
weiter ausdehnen wird in richtung südost
europa und die tiefs haben da einfach
überhaupt keine chance die tiefs
brachten heute zum beispiel über den
pyrenäen kräftige gewitter und dieses
tief hier sorgt auch dafür dass es im
südwesten deutschlands morgen schon
richtig warm wird die kältere luft die
wird hier nach und süd osten abgedrängt
und das tief über dem atlantik das
bleibt da vorerst einfach liegen so ist
es heute nacht einfach klar und ab und
zu bildet sich auch mal nebel und die
temperaturen dazu sinken auf werte
zwischen 13 grad an der nordsee und bis
7 grad am alpenrand und morgen bleibt es
nur an den küsten von nord- und ostsee
bei 18 bis 19 grad unter 20 grad warm
sonst aber steigen die werte auf 21 bis
24 grad hier in franken und dem rheintal
auf 25 bis 26 grad das wird ein sehr
sonniger freitag und höchstens in
norddeutschland gibt es auch mal wieder
so eine hochnebeldecke die sich aber
rasch auflösen sollte als heute und in
den nächsten tagen geht es sehr sonnig
weiter bei temperaturen zwischen 18 und
27 grad und dieses schöne
spätsommerwetter das hält wohl bis weit
in die nächste woche hinein an und das
sehen wir auch am temperaturen und
wettertrend für berlin sie sehen dass da
vielleicht sogar nochmal 25 grad
erreicht werden bis mitte des monats
bleibt es wahrscheinlich spätsommerlich
im nordosten guten abend